a lot of the consultancies you know now
that I speak to we're just using our
direct Network we know people Once Upon
a Time those consultancies didn't need
me with it being a small world it's like
there will be people that I know that
you guys maybe don't know or people who
are you know kind of relatively new to
the market who are not aware of you
haven't come across there will be a time
even if that's not right now that we'll
need help or what if something goes
drastically wrong and you lose three
four people then that's the exact time
that you might need me welcome back to
another episode of the recruitment
mentors podcast I'm your host heisha
mizzouz and on this week's episode I was
joined by B from IO Associates I reached
out to be because I saw her post on
LinkedIn where she became the first
female within IO Associates to hit the
15K weekly GP Milestone so in this
episode you're going to learn exactly
how B got there and it certainly hasn't
been a straightforward path to come up
to five years in Recruitment and for the
last three or so years she's been the io
Associates but before contract
recruitment she was in a environment
where she was doing perm engineering
whereas over the last three years she's
been doing it contracts within the
secure government and defense space a
completely different market now in her
first year which was around kovid she
ended up getting to around 1100 weekly
GP a ton of deals dropped and it was a
challenge she even blanked for five
months but over the last two years in
2022 she ended up building her book to
10K weekly GP and then in 2023 15K
weekly GP so you are going to learn
everything around how the hell she got
there the biggest challenges what she
would do differently so yeah this is
going to be a real master class on all
things contract recruitment building
relationship building your client and
also just building confidence in your
own internal mindset enjoy the episode B
welcome to the podcast thank you thanks
for having me
Second Time Lucky yeah
yeah feeling better I am I am obviously
the first time I was feeling a bit rough
they want to get in the Pod studio and
not feeling 100 no so here we are thanks
for making the trip from Bristol
appreciated did you come to London March
not as much as I'd like to yeah so yeah
it's great to be here did you grow up in
Bristol
um no I'm actually Welsh really yeah and
there's about as far west as you can go
in from a place called temby in
pembrokeshire um okay not much going on
how far is Wells from Bristol
um well where I'm from two and a half
hours so long enough um is Bristol home
now
I met someone today who said if I was to
live somewhere else it'd be Bristol and
I haven't I feel I haven't spent enough
time there yeah that's great
um it took me a while to get used to it
was different to anywhere I'd ever been
before but um yeah I've been there
nearly five years and I can't imagine
being anywhere else I love that cool so
today we're gonna unpack this
recruitment Journey that you've been on
sure so I guess before we start with the
million pound question
I want to unpack some of the like just
just some high level details so you've
you'll come so you've been in
recruitment content for five years
I think today what we're going to really
focus on is this contract Journal that
you've been on with IO so for the last
three and a bit years you've been with
IO is it Associates yes cool so you've
been specifically in the IT contract
space in the secure government and
defense sector yeah so high level
details in this order can unpack year
one performance for B Jan 2021 your
weekly GP was 1100.
year 2022 Jan
10K weekly GP and then what actually
prompted me to reach out was I saw your
post Jan 2023
first female contract biller in IO
Associates I think I've got that
correctly to hit the 15K weekly GP Mark
yep is that right yeah
absolutely amazing achievement and
obviously today we're going to talk
about
how the hell we got there right what we
learned the way the challenges all of
that but I guess before we do I'd love
to hear sort of your take from
everything everything that you've
learned the people you met along the way
like in your opinion what
characteristics and traits do you
believe make up a highly successful
recruiter in in today's market yeah
absolutely so there's a number of things
and I think the the most two obvious
ones that sort of stand out would be
resilience
um and tenacious
um I think everyone knows that
everyone's aware that you know those are
very important traits I think you know
when you when you really unpack it um
somebody has an intrinsic why as to you
know why they're doing recruitment um
it's not an easy job
as I'm sure anyone listening you know
knows
um so I think you know somebody has to
have something deeper than just I'll
work hard or you know I'm motivated
they've got to have something internally
that when they have those down days when
they're really really going through a
really you know hard patch they've got
something inside of them that's kind of
pushing them you know to keep going um
so I think being aware of that why and
being able to dig deeper and find it is
um it's definitely what I'd say is most
important what what what's been your why
then let's start I'll show you what I
might ask that I said indeed yeah so um
yeah I came I guess it goes back to sort
of upbringing um so both my parents when
I analyzed it have all the traits that
you know you would want from a
successful recruiter they couldn't do
anything more different
um so living in rural Wales and then
yeah they've um decided to go and set up
their own tourist attraction which is
actually a dinosaur park for kids love
that a bit wild but um you know they've
both been super super successful and I
think growing up seeing them you know
literally start from scratching and
build that business you know and I've
seen them struggling and go through
times when things they're not having a
good year or you know they make a
decision that you know didn't pay off or
you know wasn't wasn't the right one
um but you know they've never stopped
working hard they've never not stopped
wanting more
um and equally you know kind of I guess
pushing that onto myself as well yeah
exactly do you think you're so like
maybe when you first started out in
recruitment like do you feel like
because I always think your wife can
almost evolve like I think sometimes
like if you sort of sit there and go
right I need to figure out my why it
might be a quite difficult thing to do
like do you feel like you're sort of why
has evolved over time yeah absolutely I
think you know at the start I I probably
didn't have or wasn't aware of what what
my why was
um you know I knew I wanted to make them
proud um as obviously most people do but
it wasn't so kind of obvious to me
um and I obviously at that stage hadn't
had to to dig even and have those those
hard days
um you know some peoples might just be
that if they've grown up in you know not
a nice area not a nice house and so they
want to buy a million pound house I know
that's one of one of my colleagues um so
it definitely evolves and I think once
you've had a little taste of of success
and and it go well that you know really
helps you to you know to find what that
intrinsic Y is
okay so let let's unpack this contract
Journal that you've been on then so
obviously prior to you doing it contract
you was increment if I'm wrong perm
engineering yeah that's correct so like
how different would you say that is to
like your world now it couldn't have
been more different really okay so like
let's just let's just first talk about
that because I feel like
like that can oftentimes be something
that a recruiters are quite
um
what's the word fearful of like if I'm
doing well in certain sector or I'm in a
certain sector and I'm starting to let
you know what I would want a new channel
of these things but I'm gonna have to go
into a new sector that that can yeah a
lot of people might be really worried
about that so I guess firstly maybe it'd
be good if you could share like what was
B's approach to like get into grips with
with this market like looking back how
did you go about that yeah sure so I
made the move to IO
um just before covered so pretty bad
timing on my part
um but yeah so it's um November 2019
um so I had a couple of months to to
start getting to grips with tech
um which I really really struggled with
I had no idea what my initial Market was
Java had no idea you know what that was
and even like looking at a CV I couldn't
tell whether it's good whether it's bad
I just didn't really know where I was
starting
um and obviously then covered her um and
I was just getting set back after step
back speaking to clients I had done a
couple of deals um and all of those
dropped
um so it's back to zero out and uh yeah
obviously tough to deal with especially
when you're not you're not in an office
surrounded by you know your colleagues
your friends to to be helping you
um so I just spent all my time speaking
to candidates because I was Finding when
I was speaking to clients it was we're
not hiring like and you always felt
silly calling them to try and get jobs
um so I just decided to spend that time
maximizing on you know speaking to my
network finding out from them
um you know the trends you know all this
kind of stuff um and I came across um
well it came across um a number of small
consultancies who were hiring
um all of them were specifically within
sort of Essie and DV cleared work
um so you know what does that stand for
um so security cleared and developed
vetting both super high levels of
clearance
um which are primarily used within
Ministry defense
um or secure government work
um really interesting
um obviously there's a lot of stuff that
I'm not allowed to know so it does make
it hard to recruit for sometimes but
um yeah I just maximized on on that time
with my candidates and just ask them as
many questions as possible to really get
a good understanding of of how it all
worked and like if it's okay let's just
talk about this for a sec because I
think this would be really helpful for
people so like how looking back like
what would this sort of conversation
sound like because I think when I speak
to recruiters particularly early on this
is something that people do struggle
with they're not sure how to to grips
with obviously you can go on Google you
can read articles you can listen to
podcasts these things but obviously one
of the great things that you can do is
speak to candidates and build a network
and these things so are you literally
like how are you approaching these
conversation is it very much like hey
look I'm I'm B I'm an IO Associates like
um I may not be able to massively help
you right now I'm new to the market I'm
sort of really Keen to learn and
understand like I'm and then just asking
questions like what did those
conversations actually sound like for
you to actually learn from these people
because I think sometimes people are
fearful of looking and feeling stupid
yeah and like you're recruiter calling
these candidates up so you're meant to
be the expert in these things you get
what I'm in yeah no of course
um so yeah I think you know initially
they were very much you know I'm new can
you help me what can you tell me
um but they evolved and it it became you
know as as we got deeper into covert it
became me being able to give them
something back so I was able to tell
them you know if they'd been out of a
job since March or or you know whenever
I was able to tell them look this
consultancy are hiring I can't help you
I don't actually work with them but I
know from speaking with other candidates
that these guys and and this company are
are hiring so because you were you know
tipping them off you were giving them
information that really wasn't actually
going to help you they were so happy to
to give something back
um and it's funny when I look back now
actually two of the clients I work with
um the candidates that I'd obviously
given those kind of tip-offs to ended up
referring me into consultancies further
on down there
um it's just about the bigger picture
and it's you know recruitment's a long
long game so this is this is so
interesting right because we were
talking about this yesterday and um
a training session that we did but like
how like now you can you can see that
with hindsight but like when you're in
it it's hard it's sometimes hard to see
the bigger picture yeah did you know
what I mean absolutely so like I don't
know if there's any like buy you sharing
that story that's massively helpful it
makes people feel like I know what doing
the right thing and helping people it's
not necessarily always about getting
something in return however that will
likely be remembered it will be
memorable I have helped them so they
might they're at some point that might
come back and if it does great but like
how come like how can we help recruiters
understand or see the bigger picture
when they're in the thick of they've got
a Target to hit that month they've do
you know what I mean
yeah it's it is tricky
um and I think the the reason I was
lucky was because of kovid there was
maybe less pressure and I think
something that you know has helped since
then is maybe looking at things in
quarters or you know a six-month period
as opposed to every month like I've got
a score I've got to do a deal you know
not everyone you know not everyone is
going to be perfect and there's only
sort of 30 31 days in a month so stuff
can roll you know but you know if you've
not scored one month that means you
might do six seven deals the next so
that was definitely something to help me
um I think when I go back to to me being
in those you know in those shoes it was
it was just very much
sort of thinking you know I've got to be
doing something if I'm calling clients
and they're saying no well fine what can
I be getting from these candidates you
know still be still be pushing to get
leads to get any sort of Market
information that I can and um yeah it's
obviously paid off I love that so okay
cool so let's talk about them what it
sounds like is you stumbled across this
Niche yeah and you ended up really
focusing on yeah so talk me through I
think that this is important and
hopefully this comes across like and I'm
sure you drive this with your team now
yeah like I hear all the time
particularly in contract leads leads
leads get information all that is
massively important maximize the camera
calls you need to go what's going on all
that
now what I'd love you to share is like
there's one thing getting the
information then there's another thing
acting on it so like what what is it
that you picked up on
that then made you go hang on a minute
there's a potential opportunity here so
like what is it that sort of what was
maybe some of the lagging indicators or
just something that you really started
to pick up on to go you know what I'm
really going to commit to trying to
maximize this information I keep hearing
yeah sure well look I think it's you
know everyone talks about having a niche
everyone talks about you know kind of
having that one special area that you
focus on because you can't you know you
can't call a club a client and say I'm a
specialist in in Java because yeah I
find however how many other recruiters
are you know are trying to focus on Java
um but you know when you Niche that down
into looking at you know security
cleared or you know candidates with
develop vetting working in these kind of
smaller um markets you know you can
really be a specialist so I think
you know one of these candidates were
telling me these these clients are
hiring it was trying to have a you know
have a look at candidates maybe who were
already working there be CV stripping
you know looking at places they'd work
previously having you know having
conversations with them going through
their LinkedIn connections so you know
who they're connected with and why
they're working and you know you just
kind of really start to build up this
list and you know essentially Market
mapping who your target clients are
going to be
um I think once you start sort of
ticking them off as well like you know
once you've managed to get one on
um you know if you've placed someone
you'll see you know hopefully there's a
vacancy elsewhere where they've just
come from and um it's just about kind of
you know steadily making your presence
known and then you know becoming more of
a specialist as you go through
yeah I love that it's this word uh
Market mapping like how important is
that oh gosh yeah it's yeah super super
important what was how how do you Market
map because like I'll be honest I I hear
this more when we sat down I was telling
you about um
before we started Alicia she's like huge
on this organization it's been a game
changer for her uh interviewed a guy
called
um Ethan who was like proper on this as
well Market mapping like so how how does
B market map like have you got a
spreadsheet are you is this something
that you do every single week still yeah
I definitely try to I mean it's it's
harder as you get busier
um but yeah it you know it comes from a
combination of things so speaking of
candidates and getting you know getting
leads is obviously a great way to do so
CV stripping um you know again is is
super important and it's it's you know
it's quick sometimes if you've got a
candidate who's been around for however
long they'll have you know five six
companies that are going to be Target
clients for you
um so you know it's getting those client
names
um then whether you're speaking to
candidates who are currently working
there to try and find out you know who
the who the people you want to be
speaking to are or whether it's LinkedIn
um you know there's various different
ways that you can you can track those
people down um events as well are so so
good for for this kind of thing
um yeah okay and then and then how do
you keep like I guess just curious like
what's ended up being your your system
maybe early on like did you I don't know
did you just keep like just keep growing
this ever sort of breathing like
spreadsheet or I don't know how did you
organize it yeah so um on our CRM we're
able to to code
um contacts or you know candidates up so
I guess just having a system with that
so whether I was coding coding them with
the tech they're using
um and then the level of clearance
they've got um so they're easy to then
kind of have in in a list I bet your
company love you then if you've been on
the CRM rather than a spreadsheet yeah
yeah a spreadsheets are a thing of the
past for us okay
Okay cool so so I guess what it sounded
like then there was a bit of a moment
where obviously you were sort of
recognizing this during covert that they
were hiring so then like you just tried
to obviously capitalize that and
maximize that but obviously you're
building relationships candidates you're
letting people know that these types of
companies were hiring yeah and then it's
sort of built from there so it seems
like the opportunity was more so that in
the current climate these are
consultancies that are growing rather
than like making layoffs and these
things and then that's where I guess it
then Grew From there then yeah
definitely
so talk us through like I guess it would
be useful context like this world that
you're recruiting them and my only other
um exposure to it is I did some work
with a company called Evolution
recruitment that had a team that do um
defense or like that sort of world so
like you said that it'd be useful for
um in terms of context so like when you
say there's stuff that you can't know
like what what like what like because it
seems a little bit mysterious you know
what I mean so like what what what does
it what does that actually mean in in
your world yeah okay so with what you
can say yeah be allowed to say unless
you get in trouble
um so I don't have any you know any
level of clearance myself so to get
these types of clearances you've got to
go through mega mega check so whether
that's
um you know Financial Financial type
checks um I guess right your family's
history as well it's obviously criminal
criminal checks
um any drug tests that kind of thing
it's it's you know it's it's quite kind
of intrinsic the stuff that they they go
through
um
I I think there's you know there's
obviously stuff that you're not allowed
to know because you don't hold this
clearance so the types of clients I
guess these consultancies are delivering
into will be the likes of like MI5 am I
six
um they're keeping our country safe so
you're the projects they're working on
yeah they know information you know they
can't be sharing that with me I'm not
allowed to know that at the specific
projects that you guys are working on so
surely that means like there's even more
variables here on the candidates
there are you have to go for even more
checks and maybe like a typical it
contractor would in like a not that type
of world yeah that it that's kind of all
all out of my hands you know I obviously
don't get involved in any of that and
once these guys have got these levels of
clearances they um they keep them for
you know five ten years right because
they've been through that process
exactly yeah um the tricky thing is the
clearance is lapse if they um if they
come out of a out of a roll and don't
use it for a certain period of time so
that can be super frustrating if you
found a candidate who you know has the
level of clearance you need and then
they've taken a break or they've you
know not been able to get a new a new
role in their contracts finished
um they're kind of news to you
yeah Okay cool so cool I'm glad I
understand that so I guess what what I
feel like people would absolutely love
to understand is like let's just start
with like obviously there's a whole
element of bees building her Market
You're Building credibility you're
building your Niche but why don't we
just sort of start this conversation
with like obviously going from 11 100
weekly GP to 10 grand weekly GP that's
that's a big difference
so like why don't we just start with
like what would you yeah what would you
say what were some of the main things
when I say to you what was B doing
differently putting aside there's time
you're obviously hopefully slowly
learning improving you're building a
track record like what what do you think
that you were doing differently
um to sort of get to that point do you
think
so I think the main thing was once I had
got one client on in this in this
industry and had delivered you know a
project team for them so maybe six seven
eight contractors
that kind of level of credibility
um you know just really really paid off
um it's such a small world so I was
actually getting referred from you know
from this one first client that I ended
up placing with into another client
um and you know you've got these names
to refer back to
um everyone knows everyone
um so you know if I can say I work with
company x with company y that you know
turn these companies over here is
actually super super relevant
um
alongside that like it was just my I
think my work rate just kind of must
have tripled
um once you see success it's so much
easier to work hard you know you you
want to you you know what the rewards
look like you want to get on the
holidays the lunch gloves or whatever
else that you know recruitment gives to
you
um as well as obviously starting to see
some Financial rewards as well which
when you're you know you're on your
basic and you've maybe done one or two
deals you're not really getting much
commission it's it can be harder to to
be motivated
um but I think you know once once that
sort of catalyst has started
um yeah momentum yeah sure hey everyone
a real quick one from me this podcast
would not be possible without our
amazing podcast Partners Vin cherry and
Source breaker because you listen to
this podcast you're able to get your
hands on exclusive savings on both of
these award-winning products if you're a
growing recruitment business you have to
check out vincere who are an all-in-one
operating system for your growing
recruitment business with Source breaker
if you want to make sure that all of
your recruiters have the best tools on
the market to stand out and beat their
competition then you have to check out
Source breaker use the link in the show
notes in the comments below and you'll
be able to get yourself exclusive
savings on these amazing products so can
I just ask you then I know I know it
sounds really obvious but I'll be honest
like speaking to a lot of Crews at the
moment and typical and most common
challenge right now is business
development and winning good quality
business consistently or is proven to be
more and more difficult to do that
so what you're setting there is
obviously yeah we've got the benefit of
the type of Industry that you're in it
might be a bit more close-knit than
maybe some other industry is totally
fair and that makes sense
but I think when I speak to a lot of
recruiters I think what's actually
really underutilized which you just said
has been really important is showcasing
your case studies and what you've
already done so it'd be good if you like
we can grow granular here I know it
sounds really simple like oh I'll just
hold a company X that we did this at
that company but like how did you
actually approach showcasing that B has
done this for that company like how do
you actually approach it did you just
say look we've had this company so we
can help you or was it like hey look
we've just had your direct competitor
like would you be over time in a
conversation was it like hey we've
helped them solve um this problem or
we've helped them build this product you
know what I mean because I think I don't
know what you feel about this but I
think a lot of recruiters can gain that
confidence and credibility by these
things and they don't necessarily have
to be their own case studies like if I
join your team tomorrow why can't I like
use what our team's done do you get what
I mean so it'd be good if you don't mind
sharing if there is anything to share on
like how how did you actually go about
maximizing that track record because I
think a lot of people don't yeah
absolutely so I think the the first
thing I did was exactly what you just
said so you know it was to to get a
really well worded email together you
know showcasing what I've done for for
competitors
um to you know and essentially say look
you know I can I can do this here's an
example
um could we speak about you know how I
can how I can help you guys whether
that's now or in the future and I think
something really big to focus on is if
you don't know that that company are
bidding or have just won a massive you
know massive project it can be about in
the future you know it's again it's it's
going back to that this is a long game
you might not do a placement with that
company for six 12 months but if you've
kind of got ahead and you've had that
conversation so they know where you are
when they when they need you
um then you know that's that's great and
that's a win and you need to be able to
to see that
um I think you know I'd then maybe try
and follow that up with a with a bz call
but it's so much warmer because you've
already put your case across them you
know you've got that to fall back to did
you see my email and and it's not um you
know obviously it can be intimidating
making a cold call so it's it's so much
nicer to have that email there
um you know to to kind of take them
through and discuss properly love that
no that's a really good point and then
just curious I know we're going
grandmother here but this is all been
people want to help with so like no I
really like that and it sounds simple
but it's about actually doing that right
so I guess what I'd love you to just
share all your thoughts on would be if
you send me that email and I'm in your
space and I read it and it's like oh
yeah like okay that sounds interesting
she's done that for another company with
like that this person might be able to
help me at some point you call me and I
tell you that um yeah we're not actually
hiring at the moment but as you said
taking a step back think of the bigger
pictures important so like what's the
sort of why that you try and communicate
as to why that person should give you
time do you know what I mean because I
think that's that's the important thing
and I don't know what you think about
this but again speaking to a lot of
recruiters and the recruiters that have
been really successful for a long time
it's because they have got good at
thinking of the bigger picture and not
just having a short-term Focus but also
medium and long-term Focus I think
sometimes a lot of recruiters can just
be focused on are they hiring right now
if they're not okay move on so like what
would the tip call like why be around
okay like well this is why you should
give me 30 minutes so we can have a
conversation do you know what I mean if
they're not hiring I don't know yeah
yeah sure
um so I think you know I've definitely
had this a lot okay
um a lot of the consultancies certainly
um you know now that I speak to it's
we're just using our direct Network
um you know we know people and and
almost a fact it's a small world can
work against me but I guess what I what
I say to counter that is you know again
rely on the case studies that that have
worked
um because once upon a time those
consultancies didn't need me but you
know now you know look what I've done
look what I've been able to help it's
with it being a small world it's like
there will be people that that I know
that you guys maybe don't know or people
who are you know kind of relatively new
to the market who you're not aware of
you haven't come across
um so you know it's just about that you
know there will be a time even if that's
not right now that you you will need
help or you know what if something goes
drastically wrong and you lose three
four people you know in a relatively
short Pace sorry
all the time
um you know then that's the exact time
that that you might need me
um what about then surely like because
of the weather you're in surely you can
like you speak to these people all the
time so surely like also you might be
able to offer some sort of like Insight
or do you know what I mean into the
market well just in general like uh why
okay be well why why would I give you my
time if I'm not hiring and you just said
well look these types of companies
initially said that they didn't need my
help but we sort of start to build a
relationship I understood what they
might need in the future and then when
they needed me we started working
together but like surely also as well as
just people you like you speak to
similar people all the time I don't know
that surely there's other things that
you could also add value on which is why
I'd be happy to give you 30 minutes
besides just speaking about how many
contractors I need yeah yeah absolutely
I guess you know I'm hearing from from
the candidate the candidates I'm
speaking to all the time you know that
they don't they don't have that the time
to be speaking to them to be
understanding you know maybe what's
going on outside of this consultancy
um you know or you know that x amount of
people maybe come available that kind of
thing um so yeah it's about using those
conversations I'm I'm having with other
clients um you know or other candidates
um or maybe you know internally other
people are IO who do similar markets
um you know and be being able to kind of
represent that to them
so work ethic tripled yeah what does
that mean like what did that actually
look like
um
so I guess it kind of went from somebody
who wasn't you know was was wasn't
really that motivated
um you know was was struggling to to get
any wins
um and probably was feeling quite down
you know how on Earth you know you come
into Recruitment and it's yeah you'll
learn 35k in your first year and your
second you'll be on 100K and you think
yeah that's great
um yeah and I think it's it is tricky it
was kind of getting to me like you know
what am I doing I've been to UNI I've
traveled you know everything's always
been kind of Fairly easier you know it's
in the now in a situation where I'm
really not good at something and and it
was really hard to kind of overcome that
I think at the time I'm going banging on
now about you know look at the bigger
picture that kind of thing but gosh at
that time
yeah yeah it was all just like what
where are my wins why aren't I winning
now
um and I was I was definitely impatient
um impatient yeah but when I look back
now it's like you know those there was I
was definitely learning learning in that
whole that whole time I want to look
back and I'm like yeah I want to change
any of that for the world she was yeah I
think this is an interesting thing right
I was listening to podcasts the other
day yeah and I don't know what you think
about this and it's like
when you're in your career
like particularly when you're like
building your career I think he was just
uh this person just saying about how
like leaning into like learning rather
than earning is a probably a good
strategy over the long term yeah so like
what it sounds like what you shared then
is like what you recognize is okay I
might not be earning what I feel like
should be and I might be being a bit
impatient about why I'm earning however
let's actually put a lot more value on
how much I'm learning like how much I've
improved since when I started and like
how much more I know about my market now
and how many more people that I do know
do you get what I'm in yeah absolutely
it's funny one of the things that I say
to my guys all the time now
um is if you're not if you're not
winning then you're learning because you
know absolutely if something goes wrong
it's like what can I learn from this and
then and the fact that you're able to
learn something from it the fact that
you're able to take something away is a
massive one in itself
so a lot of people feel those things
that you felt and quit yeah
so like why didn't you then
I couldn't have gone back home and said
you know I can't do it I think that it
probably were a time someone I did call
her so God I I don't want to be here I
don't know what I'm doing but I don't I
don't have it I didn't think I had it in
meter to actually turn around and say
you know to myself you know or to anyone
else I can't do this
um so that wasn't an option I was I was
going to make it work no matter you know
no matter what but um yeah there were
definitely days where I doubted it and
then like was there anything that
you started to like focus more on
compared to like not getting the big win
of getting a contractor or whatever I
don't know if there's anything that you
could sort of pinpoint that you started
to just have a bit of a perspective
change or start to focus on different
things and then that and then when you
did then actually get the outcome that
you wanted five contractors out or
whatever that only then sort of helped
things like
yeah definitely I think
um even now
um you know tiny little winds still can
come ruin a lot um you know if I come
across a new consultancy that I know
require the types of clearances that I
recruit for I'm buzzing that's that's my
day mate um you know and and even now
it's funny I celebrate a new candidate
in my market who's looking if it's not
someone I know or even if it is someone
I know and and they're back on the
market sometimes I celebrate that more
than a job because I know how to check
it these people can be to find
um and when I take that back a notch to
maybe
um my more Junior days it you know that
was very much the same
um you know whether it's a new candidate
whether it's a lead for a company I
hadn't heard before
um you know that that itself is a huge
win yes that's a really good point for
everyone listening to yeah not just sort
of make your wins the end outcome right
because if if you if you do that then
you're always gonna I don't know there's
gonna be less wins right and it's it's
going to be a lot more difficult
particularly when you're feeling like
you're not getting any of the results
but you might have been making progress
in a whole bunch of other areas yeah
exactly so taught me talk me through
then so obviously you said that you
really sort of double down on your work
ethic
um people love knowing Day plans on this
podcast
yeah they really do so like talk me
through it could be more like more
recently now but maybe so when did you
when did you start
um the sort of management Journey
because are you on the management
Journey have you got people in your team
yeah I am so when did you start that
um February last year February last year
yeah okay so maybe we could do it
because I feel like you're gonna have to
incorporate like management one-on-one
stuff yes yeah so before you had team
members what was like b's day plan was
it pretty regimented like what what did
that look like particularly as you were
obviously growing this contract book
yeah so definitely tried to be
um obviously sometimes things go out the
window
um but my main focus certainly in the
mornings was always candidates
um you know if I was speaking to
candidates I'd have targets so I'd want
to be getting you know a couple of leads
um you know ideally some new hiring
sites and more importantly within that
contract the hiring sites um as well as
contractor team sizes because that can
tell you so much you know how much
potential does this client have um if
any if they're if this person's in the
team with I don't know one contractor
then it's probably not going to be a
massive sort of Target client for you
but if they're on a team of 15
contractors and uh the pound sign sort
of start starting okay so morning
candidates yeah yeah yeah
pretty much and then before lunch you'd
probably send out
um any shot to clients of maybe the
hottest candidate I found that day
um and then the afternoon would be BD so
whether that was quite sort of calling
through that um a shot I just sent out
um hey have you seen my email what your
thoughts Miss candidate and trying to
sell them in
um and then you know admin and and sort
of lesser things at the end of the day
talk me through like I just feel like I
did permanent recruitment right okay so
I don't know I just feel like every time
I sit down with a contract recruiter
like so much of it is centered around
like information
but you just said there in terms of like
size of contract site how many
contractors are with all that
so I don't know like just curious like
how what advice do you have for people
to
um be better at getting information
because like surely you don't want the
other person on the end of the phone
feeling like she's just trying to get
information out of me do you know what I
mean yeah so like if that's absolutely
crucial which it sounds like it is
information acting on it leads getting
leads all this how have you got better
at getting information and do you have
advice for people that do want to get
better at that without surely the other
person just feeling like they're just
trying to get all this information out
of me how much value they're giving me
yeah it's got to be a conversation
um you know if you if you hear newbies
on the phone sometimes it's like they
call up and they go through their
candidate qualification sheet and they
ask the questions but there's they don't
give anything back
um and so you know you put yourself in
like candidate shoes if you're speaking
to someone who's asking you a lot of
questions so it sounds so scripted why
are you gonna trust them with any
information
um whereas if you know you're kind of
having a proper chat with them you know
you're invested you're actually wanting
to understand more about them which
obviously is still asking questions but
it's asking more genuine questions
um and you know one thing that that I've
definitely found is you're not you're
not necessarily going to get leads loads
of information on that first call but if
you're the recruiter that's calling
those candidates back that's saying I'm
really sorry the rollout of the poetry
about has been put on hold or it's been
filled internally yes it's a negative
update but they really really appreciate
that update and that continuity and you
know on the fourth fifth sixth call
they're probably starting to trust you
and at that point they're more willing
to to share information and to share
leads with you yes I'm making a yeah
like less transactional basically
exactly okay that's that's interesting
and then I guess what what I always like
to ask and it might be what we're
talking about but from from your
perspective what do you believe contract
recruiters have to absolutely master
to be to be great at it would you say
any particular activity or just I don't
know what comes up for you yeah so
I think the main thing is understanding
your own strengths
um
if I look at our sort of senior
leadership team across across our team
um at i o
there's sort of six of us and we all
have very different individual strengths
um we're all very different recruiters
but if I tried to to master every single
one of those you know it's probably not
doable you're never going to be perfect
and and you know there's different
personalities within that as well so I
think it's really starting to understand
where your winds are coming from and and
really maximize on those
so like what's working for you yeah
exactly what was yours then so it'd be
my candidate relationships yeah
how did you get better at that
it comes for time
um you know again it goes back to like
you can't just have one call and expect
them to give you everything
um you know but once you've you know
placing someone obviously helps
massively but even that point some of my
best relationships with candidates who
you know before I found this Niche it
was it was just candidates that I I had
the time for and I spoke to and again
sometimes sharing information that
doesn't benefit you so telling them X
companies hiring I don't work with them
but why don't you try and apply direct
or you know approach someone on LinkedIn
and then is that is like the kind of
like where would you say you mentioned
like newbies there where do you see uh
sort of people that are newer on their
contract recruitment uh Journey
typically like
fall short a lot of the time or like
struggle with early on or typical
stumbling blocks that you sort of see
people go through
um still talking about like the
candidate relationship just as a whole
lot if you've got if you've just what
you've seen like now because you've come
out the other side yeah you've obviously
yeah like really sort of continue to
build on what you've worked hard for I
don't know if there's any sort of common
stumbling blocks that you see people
make
yeah I definitely I think continuity
like so often you know you'll see a note
on the system that they called someone
they've told them they're going to be
hiring in two months time but then
there's no callback and it's you know
it's it's just left so I think
organization and and continuity are both
super duper important yeah we spoke
about this yesterday
the uh art of follow-up yeah yeah
uh it's interesting a lot of
we ask people like do you have a system
to do your follow-ups or to make sure
you never miss a follow-up yeah most
people put no not really or sometimes I
do sometimes I don't
what what's your do you have a system to
make sure that that isn't you who found
that out and then forgot to give them a
call back yeah so I just used my diary
um on Outlook very simple that's what
we're like uh
um event reminder or yeah exactly so if
I speak to someone and they say look not
right now but if you give me a call back
you know in February then yeah I'll be
lucky and then that's fine that goes
goes with my diary probably to give them
a call back a little bit before that so
I'm not you know I'm not missing it
um and yeah just just make sure that I'm
doing that
and then when it comes to then hitting
that amazing Milestone of 15K weekly GP
yeah
I feel like then you can let me know
what you think but like going firstly I
guess going into that third year was
that you're like goal did you think that
was possible
yeah so I think I think once I hit 10K
it it was kind of the realization like I
can do this
um and so naturally that you don't want
that high to end you know you don't want
to think oh I you know oh that was me at
10K
um I think the fact that no girl and I
had ever got to 15K made it something I
I really really wanted to do
um as a girl who I work with my previous
company
um and I work with the io she's one of
my closest friends and I've um you know
often been a second girl to do things
too after her
um so you know sort of 5K 10K so that
15K was you know a friendly rivalry
something I really really wanted to do
some healthy competition exactly yeah so
I feel like then when when you're in
that position rather than what we're
speaking about before it it more becomes
around like marginal gains and like
tweak and things yeah so like what were
some of the things
like you're like really focusing on
maybe like tweaking or just getting
those extra percentages out that could
potentially in the long run mean that
you then find yourself at 15K out of
Interest yeah so it's you know things
like
um sending candidates to clients you
know a little bit more so even if they
told me we're not hiring until then if I
had a good candidate like they were
getting sent because it was like you
know even on the off chance that they
might take them on absolutely like I'm
gonna send them
um I guess it was it was trying to make
the most of my margins as well so you
know what can I do here
um you know if you're working on an
average margin with someone maybe you
can get a little bit more out here and
and take a little bit less in the future
or maybe you've already taken a bit less
on on some
um you know so it was absolutely trying
to trying to you know squeeze everything
I could out of those
um and again just just trying to create
as many opportunities as possible
what as in in what sense opportunities
so if if there were any new clients I
could get on even if this was going to
be like the first placement that I made
with them you know was I kind of
specking out as much as I could was I
putting posts up on LinkedIn about these
candidates to to try and encourage
clients to maybe come to me
um just almost going back to basics and
doing everything within my power to make
sure that I was going to get to 15K and
then what have you done since
to make sure that he doesn't become
complacent
because yeah you've hit the 15K you beat
you beat your mate
first person to do this yeah you might
think right time to put the feet up you
know you could you could quite easily
lose that work ethic that helped you get
there right and
yeah oftentimes I speak to recruiters
that uh they found it the hardest to
retain the like top performer thing
because that's it's just harder to do
that right or that's actually been a lot
really difficult for people to manage
once they've actually got to like that
big goal that they've always had yeah
yeah so how how have you
have you made sure that b hasn't become
a complacent
I think I'm probably hungrier than ever
really yes it's
um it's just such a good feeling to you
know to be achieving these things that I
probably never thought I could
um I think my book's sort of 17 too at
the moment which obviously is great um
like a lot of people I've got loads of
finishes coming up at the end of March
just because of the the type of Industry
working it's it's um when contracts will
run too so I'm gonna take a bit of a hit
but it's you know I've got a solid base
now to to Really push on and grow
um so yeah 20K is is first it's now onto
the 20K first
to hit the 20K yeah there's a couple of
guys who um who had already hit the 15K
Mark but nobody's ever done 20K on io6
no one's ever done 20. yeah so it's uh
so what what's let's talk about that
then what's top of mind like again it's
again going to come down to squeezing
the juice out of things of course yeah
like how how are we gonna get to 20K so
I'm gonna I'm in an interesting spot
right now because my team's bigger than
it's ever been so they are taking
priority right now okay um 20 okay we'll
come my hat like I have no love so I'm
gonna get there
um but I'm also conscious that you know
I want to see them get into 5K 6K 7K and
um yeah hopefully my number two she'll
be she'll be pushing on for 10K soon as
herself so you know I've just had the
high of hitting that 15K
um I'm confident that that book will
will stay steady and there's you know
there's stuff there that will grow
itself but for now
um my focus has to be on them okay so
let like before we finish then let's
just talk about that how how do you
describe your your leadership Journey
what surprised you about it so far I
think that in
Italy
to recruit is everything that comes with
it you become like a full-time counselor
a full-time house you're really dealing
with you know whatever's going on
outside of work for them
um you know you have to become like
their best friend and it's it's amazing
I love it but it's it's a roller coaster
um you know because you celebrate
everyone with them you have to be the
person to keep them up in you know in
the times where they've maybe had a
dropper or you know they've had six no's
or you know whatever that might be and
you're down yourself you know you're
disappointed for them but equally you've
got to be the person that's that's kind
of bringing them back up um and I guess
be that person that you know I once had
um so yeah I say it's it's just you just
don't know what you're gonna have each
city that you come into and then you
mentioned it there I speak to a lot of
people in your position and yeah what
can be one of the most difficult things
is maintaining your performance yeah
whilst getting the best out of them so
like how how have you sort of gone about
that like in terms of I don't know what
how have you tried to sort of approach
maybe your working wheat to make sure
like B has the time B the sort of
recruiter gets time to sort of do what
she needs to does
that she gets to um done and then B's
also then they're the person you need to
be for your team like how have you
approached that yeah absolutely so I
think
um I definitely try and always be there
for them um you know I sit kind of you
know in the middle of them so I'm
accessible to them at all times other
than if I'm you know in a meeting or
whatever
um I'm lucky that I've got a delivery
consultant who very much Works alongside
me
um doesn't fill all my roles I'll still
do like you know some candidate work
myself because it's super important I'm
still embedded in in that world but um
he's helped massively
um you know he's definitely a great
support system
um and I guess as well once you get to a
point you've got established clients
that needs less work
um you've still got to keep the you know
some BD going on but certainly less than
maybe what I once was so it does allow
me to have a lot more time to you know
kind of help them with with phone
coaching or you know help with their
emails before they're sent out that kind
of thing and just make sure that
everything is being done to to a high
standard and then how how was like B uh
approached like becoming a better
manager a better leader would you say
yeah so it's it's a work in progress I
don't think you know you're ever going
to be perfect and it's not an easy job
um but I think just just trying to make
more time for them
um we do have part of our sort of
building manager course I've you know
recently been on you get 360 feedback
and that's been super helpful to
understand like what they want more of
from me it's um it's all Anonymous so I
don't know who wrote what what was like
what was the key insights
um a lot of it was positive but there
was a lot more maybe like holding them
accountable to certain things I think
that they wanted yeah I think maybe I
was very accountable holding myself
accountable to Target but sometimes with
them if they weren't you know weren't
hitting what they said they were going
to hit maybe I wasn't you know pushing
us to as to the why
um so yeah it's definitely been helpful
to to know what they've wanted from me
360 feedback yeah that's good it's
important to get that if you don't get
it you know yeah I think the anonymous
is the key bet I could probably tell him
[Laughter]
the thing is though it's like with stuff
like that I feel like
people are always going to spend time
thinking and he said he said that yeah
it was quite clear I think
but yeah so how have you thought about
because I think this would be useful
because I think what you're talking
about there there is a bit of a
balancing act of like
you don't want people to feel like I
don't know you're like making them feel
like you're hitting them with a kpi
stick that people like to say or
whatever like have you thought about how
you're going to try and balance that
line of like setting standards holding
people accountable and not making people
feel like you're micromanaging them or
like they have to do this otherwise do
you know what I mean yeah of course I
think you know part of this about
getting in the trenches with them
um you know we've got a good competition
we're launching on on Monday which is it
is kpi based
um but you know I'm part of that so I'm
gonna be you know involved yeah and at
the end of the day if you can show them
the reason why these kpis are you know
being set then I think you know it's
fair enough
um you know the last thing that I would
want them to think of me was that you
know all I cared about is a kpis if
someone's done last numbers but actually
the quality of those kpis is good and
that's what really matters um but on the
flip side recruitment you know is a
numbers game so there's got to be some
element of kpis in there yeah I just do
feel like the other obviously kpr of
sort of has become almost like a bit of
a dirty word isn't it yeah yeah but like
it's just it's so I don't know how you
feel but like understanding the science
behind being successful is like super
important like most top performers that
I've sat down with like they will know
to the to the detail like if they want
to build 400 Grand in the year how many
interviews I need to book yeah exactly
and it's it's more about the science to
be like because there is a science
behind it and it's just good to
understand like where you want to try
and end up which should mean you get the
outcome that you want exactly and you
know we try and look at ratios as well
so it's you know there's it's the reason
why that kpi is happening so it's not
just why haven't you pulled however many
jobs you know it's it's well we know you
need however many jobs to do a deal so
you know that's all about exactly so
that's why we're looking at that kpi you
know there's there's a reason for it
awesome okay so as we get to the end
here then what is um what is B excited
about going uh into the the rest of 2013
you said that it's been your Market is
looking pretty good at the moment so how
how are you hoping to yeah where are you
where are you hoping to be by the end of
the year yeah so I've got two two main
goals
um the first one is to be promoted to
business manager which is a big internal
promotion essentially means you've got
um you know a successful team and uh
yeah deserve does it have that title so
it's manager yeah I'm very very hopeful
to to get that soon
um and then the second one has to be 20K
20K
when do you think you'll hit the 20K
it's a tough question
you had a crystal ball when did you like
when would you like end of the year
you'd want to be going into next year
like
books 20K
um
I'm gonna go January
um yeah it's the month 30k 10K it's a
month they did 15K so it's got to be a
trend it's magical my books are always
healthy around that time so you have to
be nice to check back in to see if yeah
I'm sure we'll see to see the post on
LinkedIn the big 20K balloon picture
uh wait to see it in uh in January but I
guess look I guess why don't we just end
with for for people listening that yeah
might be in the trenches right now might
be struggling
um in contract recruitment obviously
listening to your story might hopefully
make them feel like it is possible to
come out the other side build a
successful contract but they've seen
others build like what would your advice
be for those people that yeah hopefully
are just like sort of on the way to
hopefully get into sort of where you are
what would your advice be for those
people
um
um yeah dig deep find that why and use
it to help you push forward
um like every little win you get is a
big win and uh yeah you'll get there
love it B thanks so much thanks so much
for having me I loved it thank you so
much for listening to the episode I hope
you enjoyed it and got value from the
conversation if you did enjoy it please
don't forget to like share and subscribe
and we'll see you in the next episode
right